for those of you who tend to not off I'm
going to tell you what I about to say
that I'm going to say it and tell you
what I said I have bad news and good
news the bad news is journalism is going
to impact more and more of your lives on
a daily basis and an almost never
stopped basis 24/7 you'll be consuming
more and more information delivered by
fewer and fewer experts the good news is
that more and more of those journalists
are being trained here at the DAO Center
by John Miller and the other faculty at
Hillsdale so that's the good news I had
a number of them come through the studio
today we pre-recorded the program and
it's remarkable the energy and the
capacity that you're mainlining into
journalism so everything I'm talking
tonight about why did we dominate talk
radio can be said to be applicable even
in advance of it occurring because there
are new media being invented as we speak
new platforms new distribution methods
and the good news is and I'll dwell on
this a little bit at length is that
Hillsdale is in the forefront of
training people to use those techniques
and I can't overestimate how important
that is over the long haul I had three
journalism students in there today all
of them want to go to Washington DC
which is terrific and all of them are
going to have 50 years of professional
capacity or more and that's a hundred
and fifty years of professional capacity
sitting in front of me and I began to
estimate the number of tweets they would
send over the course of their hundred
and fifty years and so Hillsdale is
influencing every single one of those
tweets which in turn influences the
information arc in the direction of the
country profound way so I'm very glad
grateful to be here I'm even grateful to
see Larry again largely because penny
came with him but it's great to be back
here iron is a very dangerous man to
have as a friend of course I was talking
about him on the air today and I made I
referred to him as Prince Oberon of the
radio now given that this was a
reference to popular culture he had no
idea what I was referring to it is a
character from The Game of Thrones
series also known as the red Viper a
very dangerous and
quick-witted fellow so I welcome Larry
on in it went right over his head so I
had to explain it to him later and I'm
happy to be back here I was here about
five years ago but I get mixed signals
I'm only invited in January and so it's
a kind of a passive aggressive approach
and I think it's because so many of the
faculty here have been guests on the
radio show over the years dr. ray was
talking to me earlier in welcoming me
and I haven't seen Steve Smith yet I
know if he's here yet but over the over
the period of years that we've been
doing the Hillsdale dialogue I've gotten
to know a number of of your colleagues
and your faculty members via the radio
I'll see you on the radio and I think
it's been well received and I think they
like coming on but January again again
it's always January my intern last
summer Jack Butler is somewhere here
Jack was a terrific addition to the Hugh
Hewitt show staff this past summer and
he was on today doing an exit interview
in front of as many million peoples
we're listening and I asked Jack how
he'd done he's very fast a very good
cross country and track program here so
I said Jack how did you do in the turkey
truck Cincinnati 13,000 people competed
in the turkey truck Cincinnati Jack
finished fourth Wow you know if we adopt
the Belichick rules we can just get rid
of those three next year and you'll win
and he said that would not be the right
thing to do so you've taught virtue as
well as competitiveness when I was last
here at Hillsdale I spoke about
rectitude and I did so in the context of
talking about George Washington which is
not a hard task rectitude Ness is a word
that would go easily with George
Washington and so I thought I would have
a subject tonight that has absolutely no
crossover with rectitude in George
Washington which is journalism
in fact there's zeroes recycled material
because there is generally speaking no
crossover between rectitude and
journalism we are called ink-stained
wretches for a reason and ink-stained
wretches do not summon up the image of
being in any way virtuous
on the other hand if you can find a
journalist who is virtuous you're going
to find someone or some person or
institution or organization that's going
to deeply and profoundly impact the
culture and for the good so I want to
talk a little bit about what that meant
to begin with what rectitude was and
some people think just integrity so I
actually went looking around I should
turn to Paul or Larry or one of the
philosophers to tell me what it meant
but I just went looking around in the
way that lawyers do for definitions and
various ways to approach it what is
rectitude if we're going to talk about
rectitude in a journalist and why do we
dominate the talk radio they are
connected these two subjects and first
is it just virtuous the state of being
correct in judgment I thought that was
an interesting one but I finally had to
come up with my own definition which is
virtues supported by external bearing
meaning that not only do you have the
internal core of virtue but that you are
externally understood to be by people as
being virtuous now how many of those do
you think of when you think of
journalism now I understand that Carl
Bernstein for example contributed a
significant amount to the direction of
the country but I don't think of him as
virtuous Jack German who wrote a
wonderful book called the fat man in the
middle row Jack Sherman I used to watch
every week on Washington we can review
in the McLaughlin group I loved him but
I didn't think of him as being
particularly rectitude miss recently the
editor-in-chief of the New York Times
referred to a critic of his newspaper
who had criticized him for not
publishing the Mohammed cartoons in very
direct and extended terms as an orifice
and he did it in an email and he made it
public not rectitude enough in my view
on the other hand there are many who are
I think of Mark Steyn as having
incredible rectitude and I I know he's
been a guest here on the on the campus
he's got such courage he has courage in
abundance beyond any other journalist
that I know in any situation he will
just speak the truth plainly and he's a
man who's lived a virtuous life I know
some other ones for example William F
Buckley elevated every room that he ever
went into and I was only in a couple of
them but I am told and John Miller would
probably know this better than I and
there's some here will know
Buckley very well that
he was indeed who he thought him to be
and was a joy to be around Joseph
Epstein who is great sure campus the
number of times seems to me to be a
particularly great example of someone
who possesses not only great amount of
talent but a remarkable amount of
rectitude he has a new book out a
literary education which shines a light
on his young life which allows you young
people to understand if you have not yet
been rectitude Nuss you can be in the
future
he lived one heck of a life in Chicago
when he was young but I am I
nevertheless think of journalism is not
something in which people are going to
find but then you turn to politics and
you ask who's got rectitude in politics
today on Saturday in Iowa there was a
remarkable parade of would-be presidents
that included people who've been on
campus Ted Cruz they had Marco Rubio
Marco Rubio is not there I correct
myself
they had Carly Fiorina they had Scott
Walker Scott Walker strikes me as being
an individual who's just overwhelmed
over overflowing with rectitude he
believes in what he says he lives the
life that he says he's going to lead and
he absolutely gives you confidence in
his transparency and authenticity and
that is part of that rectitude thing so
if you want to improve the public you've
got to elect people like that in order
to elect people like that you've got to
have a media that will celebrate those
virtues and if in fact you find those
virtues to be corny or you find those
approaches to politics to be
old-fashioned or helplessly out-of-date
you're not going to have a media that is
supporting virtue in the public square
now I think that there's a model out
there and it's talk radio that shows how
to succeed in the new media world and
that's why I wanted to talk a little bit
about how conservatives came to dominate
talk radio because I think it's going to
teach us how concerns are going to come
to dominate the new media as well
there's a lot of media everywhere at all
times
last night I drove over I was in
Washington DC yesterday to participate
Meet the Press which is quite an honor a
high occasion it's the the biggest brand
in all of media I had not been invited
before I was pleased to go I shared the
stage with Tom Brokaw
who wrote The Greatest Generation in
boomers and anchored the NBC Nightly
News and he's a fine guy South Dakotan
plain-spoken I don't know his politics
well enough to guess Kareem abdul-jabbar
was in the house so that was kind of
interesting took all the pressure off
because no one wanted to talk to you
they all on talked to cream and Chuck
Todd who's turned out to be quite a
remarkably good moderator he asked
questions and he allows you to answer
the questions which is my model and has
been the model of journalists I've
admired across the political spectrum
for a long period of time just to let
the questions to be asked and to be
answered so I went from the height of
that to driving across from Detroit last
night flew in before the storm got to
the East Coast and I was listening to
various I was listening to BBC World
News service last night and fascinating
couple of reports but then it it got off
on some tangent that I was not
interested in whales or something and so
I turned to ESPN Radio and I heard an
interviewer talking to Jerry West how
many of you know Jerry West is
incredible basketball story one of the
greatest basketball players of all time
14 years at the Lakers then it became a
coach of the Lakers general manager of
the Lakers maybe one of the greatest
basketball geniuses ever and I was
listening to the interviewer ask
completely inane questions of Jerry West
thinking to myself here is here is a
person that you could ask about any
about shooting under pressure about
winning working with Wilt Chamberlain
Elgin Baylor you could ask him to
compare the teams of them to the
contains of now the Cavaliers with
LeBron and Kyrie and Kevin Love versus
Baylor and Chamberlain and Jerry West
and instead it was it was pablum and I
thought that is such a perfect
illustration for the audience I stopped
and pulled over and said make sure you
tell them that every interview you here
is either well done or poorly done and
that person did not execute very well
because that individual and I I know his
partner a little bit who was not doing
the interview was not prepared to talk
to Patton done any preparation wasn't
ready for the opportunity to take a
mundane fifteen minutes and turn into
something special not ready for the
moment so much of journalism is this way
there are so many eyes and ears
available right now
Gillette Facebook has 1.3 billion active
participants twitter has 284 million
accounts Skype has 300 million snapchat
which is really relatively new has 100
million these are all platforms that did
not exist a decade ago so a decade from
now the number and opportunities for
people to influence the culture and the
politics of the culture will be so much
greater than anything we've seen before
and they're all going to be possessed of
the opportunity to either be good at it
or to be like that interviewer last
night and miss the opportunity to
influence so why did talk radio dominate
when it came along first the brief
history of talk radio it did not exist
before 1989 oh they were local
absolutely local hosts like Michael
Jackson and Los Angeles a man with a
great British accent and a used to be a
liberal but he came increasingly left as
it went on Michael Jackson lost engine
and there were Joe Pyne was sort of a
deeply conservative arch right winger
Pete Franklin sort of invented sports
talk out of Cleveland moved to New York
there are a number of people did it but
it was not national because of one
federal government rule called the
Fairness Doctrine and the Fairness
Doctrine mandated that if you took a
position on an issue on the public
airwaves that were regulated you had to
provide an opportunity to somebody else
to make the opposite position that is if
you think about it incoherent but of
course it was the federal government so
it makes perfect sense you can't there
are too many opinions in the world to
provide equal time even on one subject
to all opinions cannot be done but
nevertheless it was mandated the
consequence of mandating more speech was
what less speech program directors and
general managers across the United
States did not want to put on
conservative or liberal voices for fear
that they would have to allow the
opposite number of less-talented ability
on to that and so there was no talk
radio the Parana stockton was repealed
by President Reagan 1988 and in 1989 we
had our first nationally syndicated
conservative talk show host the great
news is that the proof of concept was in
the form of Rush Limbaugh he was the
first
he invented the medium he built them all
I like to tell people were all just
branch offices of what he began he was
the anchor store on the am dial
and he revitalized the medium by proving
the proof of concept that people would
listen to political talk radio and
quickly thereafter there came a number
of people who would take up in the list
with him there are today about 11
national hosts of significant size but
the first three mega hits the first
three giant supernovas of talk radio
where Rush Limbaugh Sean Hannity and the
third one was pretty late the list mark
levin is a giant supernova marks an old
friend we were together in the
Department of Justice and it is our
great luck that the very first one Rush
was funny funny funny smart and fast
because he proved the concept and others
tried the second one Sean Hannity is
without question the nicest man in the
broadcasting business you cannot not
like Sean Hannity if you've ever met him
in his radio demeanor even though it can
be a very tough interviewer is that way
as well he's simply affability
personified and then the third great
supernova mark levin is a constitutional
scholar of the first rank now those
three have had monumental success in the
business there are a number of us who
have had a nice level of success beneath
them bill bennett and dennis prager
and mike gallagher and and michael
medved
laura ingraham is not in my network but
she's had terrific success if you think
of dennis miller not my network he's had
terrific success glenn beck not my
network he's had terrific success this
is not network driven these aren't
people that are my partners in fact i
compete head-to-head with mark levin and
i'm glad too because he's a friend and
he enlivens the discussion he raises the
level of the conversation that is
happening everywhere but I want to ask
you of those people that just name what
brings them in common they really know
about what they're speaking and although
no one is without flaws and some of our
number of our band of Ed collisions with
this or that small controversy they are
generally completely authentically
committed to that which they speak about
they are not trying to trick you
this is why we came to dominate talk
radio so effectively and so quickly is
that we were authentically who we said
we were I began in the business in 1989
as well in Los Angeles California on KFI
on the weekends and I went into
television for ten years and they began
doing my show presently in the year 2000
by which time rush had cleared away all
the boulders and people were interested
in syndicated talk from a perspective of
people who actually might know what they
were talking about and if you look at
the lineup I just gave you Laura
Ingraham is a Supreme Court Clerk and a
fine litigator Mark Levine is a
constitutional law scholar Glenn and
Sean have sold millions and millions and
millions of books they're also very
funny and very talented Russian courses
to agenor bill Bennett PhD JD Secretary
of Education Michael Medved JD from Yale
great film critic accomplished scholar
dennis prager
out there with perhaps the greatest
Talmud scholars at work in the public
square ever and he is this is why we
came this is why we won we didn't win
because we were first though it helped
that the person who was first was rush
we won because we were ready we were
prepared and when the Fairness Doctrine
went away what had happened there was a
vacuum not just for conservative opinion
but for prepared and talented
professionals so that when the
opportunity arose to actually speak into
the public square rush killed it the two
most successful communicators in
American public media today are Oprah
Winfrey and Rush Limbaugh
who have had sustained audiences of
greater than 20 million of course Oprah
has retired now from television for as
long as they have been on the air that's
unrivaled right just the numbers are
unrivaled don't let anyone ever tell you
other than the fact that the two most
successful communicators in America are
Oprah and Rush both of them work very
very hard at what they do but we bring
to it different from the other media
complete transparency and this is why
the vacuum developed over a period of
time beginning in 1967-68
the media went left why did the media go
left I'm sure John Miller teaches this
and I'm sure that everyone in this
audience that is at my age or older 58
or older knows this if you grew up
during that era it went left because of
Vietnam and the
sexual revolution and it went left very
hard and the media which used to be a
conservative organization if you think
back to the people who actually ran the
newspaper chains and owned the networks
a very button-down live by the rules
support the order fell apart as rapidly
as the culture did and the media went
left in a hurry
largely because it was paying off to be
left and so overnight almost as Harvard
went left the media which was fed by
Harvard and by that I mean all the elite
institutions followed it so that over
time that which was supposed to be the
genuine purveyors of real opinion and
genuine journalism which is Michael
Kelly the late Michael Kelly's a craft
not a profession a craft began to tilt
began to tilt began to tilt because we
replicated each other so if you were a
New York Times editor you would hire a
crimson editor from Harvard and if you
came out of Harvard in the 1960s and the
1970s you would be almost certainly
left-of-center I know of one
conservative alum of the Harvard Crimson
Grover Norquist the only one I know of
and Grover was a Harvard I wouldn't have
anything to do with newspaper when I was
there because it was run by left-wing
lunatics and I was a conservative and
then so I wanted nothing to do with the
papers but the papers would replicate
and they would send in to the great
media organizations of the day the next
generation of media people and so I went
further and further to the left so that
before long most of Americans not begin
to hear themselves in the media they
began to hear other than themselves in
the media they began to hear Walter
Cronkite declaring that Vietnam was lost
they began to hear a constant fusillade
against any Republican but especially
Richard Nixon who was of course a
polarizing force they heard Ronald
Reagan was one of the great men of the
20th century regularly derided as an
idiot they I can go back and people talk
about how tough partisan politics are
now believe me as a veteran of the
Reagan White House it was just as tough
in the 80s if not more tough and how
they insulted the Gipper but that was
because there was uniformity in the
newsroom up until 1989 there was no
challenge to the orthodoxy when that
broke Russia arrived and suddenly where
did that audience
come from it came from everyone who
understood intuitively that they were
not being served truth or at least a
differing opinion they did not they are
not easily fooled the American people
it's very hard to fool them sometimes
they want to be fooled I think they
wanted to be fooled in 2012 they wanted
to be fooled in 2008 but I don't think
they want to be fooled anymore but in
1989 when Rush arrives and changes the
paradigm they knew what they were being
given was not fair and was not balanced
what happened in 1996 I've just given
you a clue the Fox News Channel was
launched in 1996 rush had actually
proven the concept that there was an
audience for center right or even purely
conservative thinking and that if you
broadcast from that perspective which
inherently has within it fairness and I
challenge you ever to find a period of
news as opposed to opinion programming
on Fox that is not fair and balanced
they do represent both sides regardless
of what the Left says you will always
find a position perhaps of inferior
numbers but always represented well by a
man or a woman of the left on the Fox
News Channel but the Fox News Channel
launched in 1996 and into that that wake
that Rush had created there was an
audience ready to prosper it even his
talk radio prospered and began to spread
out across the United States syndicated
everywhere so the rush would have 600
channels 600 channels in every city you
could find Rush what is Fox News now
other than the ESPN the most demanded
cable news network why is that because
people like you who come not just to
conferences like this but can't afford
to come here get away from work but
drive back and forth to their house
every day want to hear what they
understand to be authentically true
because the people believed in what they
were saying and they honestly weren't
trying to trick you they were being
virtuous now I have a list of some of
the people who have recently practiced
virtuous journalism and I think you can
all say about them the same things that
I've been saying about some of these
other people George will Charles
Krauthammer
Brit Hume
fred barnes bill kristol these are all
good men and i know men better than I
know women so I'm just going to speak
about people I know personally and well
I've spent time with them I know them
well they've been on the radio with me a
lot they are who they say they are and
they're not trying to trick you they're
trying to persuade you but they're not
trying to trick you Charles cron Homer's
book a nonfiction collection of essays
sold a million-plus copies in 2014
any of those of us I'm hoping dr. arns
new book in the fall sells a
million-plus copies but I'm not going to
hold my breath may take a couple of
years no one has ever seen anything like
a series of books a book of a series of
essays previously published sell a
million-plus copies why is that because
people trust Charles Krauthammer
why do they trust him number one he's
really smart number two he has suffered
obviously and evidently there is nothing
about self-pity about him he is funny
and he's always prepared fred has told
me that of all the people who's ever
appeared that he's appeared with and
Fred's done a lot of television and
radio instead Charles works the hardest
to be ready so does I would argue rush
so does Sean people don't know the
amount of preparation that goes into
actually delivering something that
someone will watch it won't be that
interview that I heard last night and
what I am hoping to persuade you about
is that the next level of media the next
generation being trained here at
Hillsdale if they bring these same
qualities to this vast array of
instruments will influence the culture
purposefully and wonderfully well
because it's never been this easy to get
into media it's never I was asked at
lunch today by Jennifer I don't know if
Jennifer is here at wonderful lunch with
Jennifer and Janet today and a bunch of
great students and Jennifer how did you
end up in media and I can honestly say
I've never asked for a job in media in
my entire life people have called me up
which does not happen and there are
eight crucial words which I told Matt at
lunch the most 8 crucial words for a
young person to know have you ever
considered and I know a guy and so when
I got a telephone call
from a KFI program director in 1989 have
you ever considered doing talk radio I
said why not
it's got to be working and I absolutely
it did be working so I would start out
in that writer that doesn't happen
anymore that was the bad news you had to
be invited into the club up until fairly
recently
now you can force your way in by sheer
talent and hard work and training which
is what I'm going to come to at the end
here about what John Miller we dominated
talk radio because we were ready we were
prepared we were who we said we are and
we performed well and we worked very
hard at it now in front of us is this
new media world which includes by the
way micro videos you realize that most
young people will watch something for
less than 90 seconds before they make up
their mind but it's a very acquired
skill before they will they will turn it
off so you have to catch them you have
to grab their attention the attention
span of the average Hillsdale student
I'm quite certain is much greater than
the average attention span of the
ordinary student so you've got to be
able to get the hook in then you've got
to be able to entertain an informant at
the same time shape and form so - John
Miller and his young charges I have sort
of five challenges first you have to
teach them to be good first you have to
teach them to be good Michael Kelley was
before mark Stein came along my Thursday
first segment guest in the radio
business Thursday is the most important
day for a lot of reasons having to do
with how you rate shows and gain revenue
and AD Thursday is in the first segment
that's why mark Stein anchors that he
has for years but before mark started
Michael Kelley was there
Michael Kelley was killed in the march
to Baghdad in 2003 December of 2003 for
the three years prior that he had held
down that slot that mark now holds and
Michael Kelley was a good man how many
of you know his name he was an
extraordinarily gifted writer and his
parents were both journalists and
Michael would say again and again and
again journalism is a craft it's not a
profession all you have to do is be good
with words and with ideas and no one can
stop you from entering
he also wrote one of the greatest
columns of all time which I recommend
you googled tonight Christmas lights
michael kelly because all of the world
is divided into those who like white
lights and colored lights michael kelly
was a colored lights mine man as am i
but some people are white lights men and
women and to them is their own domain
his wife was a white lights woman so
when a colored lights man marries a
white lights woman conflict ensues and
that's what this column is about it's a
beautiful piece of writing it's a
beautiful piece of writing go and read
that but he was a good guy and he was
very humble very self-effacing and why
in the world was the editor of the
Atlantic and a syndicated columnist and
a Washington Post editor who didn't need
to do anything why was he in an mm wrap
in going into Baghdad where an RPG could
knock him into the river where he
drowned in the Euphrates what was he
doing there he was a journalist he was
working that's what he wanted to do he
wanted to be where the story was so that
would enrich his experience of everyday
life and he could bring it forward to
people that's why he was good he was
really good because he believed it
number two I think the best journalist
and the reason that we have dominated
talk radio is to an individual that I
have just discussed I've left some
people out purposefully but everyone
I've talked about is gracious it doesn't
mean they are never angry I've had a few
memorable confrontations on the air
myself they're infrequent sometimes
anger entrance into it anger doesn't
mean not virtuous but I'm usually not
angry and I try very hard to be very
gracious even with my left wing lunatic
callers when they get through and I make
up habit of inviting lefties onto my
show and hoping that they show up and
that we have some great conversations EJ
Dionne is regularly on my show Joanne
Reid from MSNBC Jonathan alter from
Bloomberg I like liberals and men and
women on the left to come on just a
model how conversation can occur and I
find in the people that I have named
inevitably they are gracious gracious
gracious even when they are confronted
with overwhelming evidence of duplicity
or ignorance and that's when it's really
hard to hang on to your belt just say
don't lose it because this is simply so
bad but they are gracious Oh be good
purposefully
intentionally good and be gracious
number three be grateful and be able to
name the people who gave you the
opportunities in the business because it
creates in you a desire to make sure
that there are other opportunities along
I don't know how John gets all these
Hillsdale students their gigs except he
must have been incredibly gracious and
opening to other people because all of
these Hillsdale students are finding
opportunities that just don't exist for
a lot of journalism programs in America
and if you come to Hillsdale just from
what I've known for ten years you're
going to end up with a shot doesn't mean
you're going to win or succeed in
journalism because of these other
qualities I've talked about but if you
got onto the radio you could win you
could dominate by truthful factual
reporting and you work pretty hard but
someone had to get you onto the radio
someone had to give you an internship at
the free beacon someone had to get you
to the Wall Street Journal or to the
Washington Examiner or into Salem radio
or any of these hosts and that comes
from having been grateful and being
aware of and people in my business
almost always have an eye for talent
they know it makes you look good and
better to bring up people who are
younger than you so they're almost
always willing to work out and look very
hard number four I've mentioned I don't
think that John has to be taught this or
anyone else here teach them to work very
hard the long day of a journalist is
what goes with the territory and I
guarantee you when rush sits down I
guess it noon in the East because it's
9:00 in the West he has already been at
work for six or seven or eight hours I
know when my day starts the hardest
shift in the business is the morning
drive ship because you have to get up in
the middle of the night to be ahead of
the news and you have to be news
breaking and you have to be ready and
you have to be current that this work
ethic is not easily maintained I got
this relationship now with Chuck Todd he
comes on the show almost every Friday
invited me back and up down his show you
know I cut reached out to Chuck Todd
because when he was a nobody in the
business he ran something called hotline
how many of you know what hotline is
hotline was the only condition I had my
first radio contract they had to buy a
subscription which was phenomenally
expensive in the year 2000 four thousand
dollars a year four
hotline Chuck Todd edited it was a daily
compilation of all the political news in
the world and it was no good to you if
it didn't arrive on your desk by 8 a.m.
8 a.m. in the East 5:00 a.m. in the West
I was doing morning Drive at the time I
had to have hot line couldn't read all
those newspapers I had to have someone
else do that so what time do you think
they were getting up it's incredible how
much time so he is a very hard worker as
is everyone who's really any good at
this and so I know that the Hillsdale
dial that the Hillsdale curriculum
requires people to work a great deal to
be conversant in the subjects in which
they're going to be quizzed by dr. Rey
or anyone else that ethic wins that wins
every time
so when Larry Arne came on the show
tonight and I was complaining about the
drive here last night because the roads
were kind of slippery and I've lost my
edges in Ohio glad he said you know
those of us were about the business of
saving the country don't whine much
appropriately rebuked I shut up and got
to the interview but he was right people
are about the business of saving the
country in journalism or in talk radio
don't whine much they just do their jobs
and then finally and this is the hardest
thing and I think the reason we
succeeded the best in talk radio why did
we dominate from 1989 right to the
present it's because we actually believe
that if we lose the country loses but
the people in this business genuinely
believe in American exceptionalism and
they understand that this country is the
last best hope my friend Dennis Prager
who's a wonderful wonderful man as much
as fun as I make of Dennis triple it and
that's my esteem for him and I make a
lot of fun of Dennis Prager his last
book was called still the last best hope
600 pages dense you can't make that up
you can't pretend to believe that if
Michael Medved writes a book the 12 lies
about capitalism you can't make that up
you can't turn these things out we write
our own books
nobody ghosts them in the side you know
you cannot fabricate or counterfeit the
genuine need if you're going to be
successful in journalism of
piñon variety to be a patriot not a
parasite and rush is a patriot and he's
got his flaws we all have our flaws sean
has as far as I have my flaws with but
every single person in talk radio that I
have talked about tonight is a patriot
they want the country to succeed they're
genuinely alarmed by the direction that
it's gone in and they want to hold up
and elevate that which works now here's
the good news and which I'll close on
then we'll take some questions is that
by so doing this you end up creating a
dynamic that goes far beyond the media
you create citizen activists I don't
know where the country would be if the
Fairness Doctrine had not been lifted in
1989 I don't I don't know where people
would have gone to prove the concept
that rush proved no rush no Fox News no
rush no Fox News no George W Bush why
because of rather gate because in the
wake of those two things came the blog's
so it was first it was rush and talk
waited then it was the Fox News Channel
and then the conservative blogosphere
came up prior to 1989 there was the
National Review there was the American
Spectator and a few very high-end
publications that people could enjoy if
they had money and leisure but it was
still by mail and the Pony Express
afterwards everything began to flood the
zone so we are winning because of that
transition and if we keep turning out
craftsmen like John and you are turning
out here we're going to win because we
have the added benefit to quote
Kissinger of it being true we're on the
right side and that's why we dominated
we won because it was right that's why
we're going to win the next generation
thanks for having me tonight by the way
we do this thank you very much mr.
Hewett we have some microphones roving
here if you'd raise your hand and please
stand when they come to you and they
will hold on to the mic so try not to
wrestle it from them we've got a little
while here so please ask away and we'll
ask
we'll go till about nine o'clock that's
right yeah I'll go longer if you want
but it's cold out there go ahead thank
you for speaking us today
miss Atkinson who was here yesterday
told us that there's not a systemic
media bias that there are good reporters
who want to get important stories out
but it's the editors and executives who
self-select do you think that there is a
systemic bias or what's the case with
the media today
excellent question reflecting a good
journalistic sensibility because you
listen carefully to what you had to say
yesterday I disagree with her there is a
deeply systemic bias because of who
selects to go into it UNPROFOR me so
that most as I said the career path for
most of the elite media organizations
beginning the IV's and they self
perpetuate and they are not going
through the Hillsdale rigor you can you
cannot take any classes at all but if
you're on the crimson editorial staff
you'll find a job in big media you'll be
at CNN I had a very telling experience
with the senior political economy
reporter for the Huffington Post and it
was painfully embarrassing to him I'm
not going to name him because it became
evident to me in about five minutes for
the senior political economy reporter of
the Huffington Post that he had not a
clue about the world he was covering but
he had a lot of opinions he had not even
heard of desert fox desert fox was the
operation against Saddam's weapons of
mass destruction launched by Bill
Clinton in 1998 he presumed to critique
George W Bush on the basis of striking
at non-existent WMD so I asked him to
square up with desert fox how could Bill
Clinton have been right but George W
Bush wrong he was unaware of Desert Fox
he was the senior political economics
correspondent for Huffington Post how
could he possibly write anything that
made any sense at all he'd come out of
the University of Virginia
how had he gotten hired came out of the
University of Virginia he said the right
things he had the right attitudes he
told me he had marched in a couple of
demonstrations against the war
if the intake valve is bad and it lets
in everything and everything isn't
required to learn anything you have
systemic bias so I think I don't know
how Cheryl's path went but I I find I
find it astonishing that people have not
read I can't I won't name people
individually the the looming tower the
looming towers single most important
book to have read about the war that we
are currently engaged in by Lawrence
Wright who is a man of the left and the
senior politics correspondent for The
New Yorker is the history of al Qaeda it
is the genealogy of al Qaeda from which
did they come how did they get here who
thought up Osama bin Laden turns out at
beginning Greeley Colorado believe it or
not when a man named Saiga tube who was
here in the post-world War two ERA and
became radicalized and went back to
Egypt and took the Muslim Brotherhood
which had already been founded and made
it very very radical with a couple of
books called milestones and under the
shade of the banyan tree and so this is
what this is what I think is sort of
basic first principles that you've got
to know to cover it I can't tell you how
many journalists have not read that
they're not obliged to and so the
systemic bias is really not about I'm
only going to hire people who voted for
Al Gore in 2000 it's not that crude it's
actually very sophisticated too
self-perpetuating credentialism that to
a certain extent Hillsdale is defeating
because it's created an alternative
credential one that is immediately
recognizable in the world of serious
people and conservatives so that if
you're working if you're the editor at
the Washington free beacon mat continent
and you want to know if someone's
prepared to do good work and work hard
and be correct in their facts
you see Hillsdale you'll hire it but
until that comes along they're taking us
the systemic credential to Harvard
Crimson or the University of Virginia
daily paper or the Yale Daily News and
what it once stood for it doesn't so I
think she's just wrong and we have to
disagree
there's also story selection bias which
they think she is what she was referring
to dan Rather who she probably worked
with once said News is where you look
very true if you don't have a path
forward if you don't know what you want
to find you won't you won't ever find it
in rather gay when the allegations were
made against President Bush of
non-service in the National Guard that
was a completely self-fulfilling
prophecy that they wanted to be true to
the exclusion of the evidence in front
of them it was false that's how deep the
systemic bias was his producer at the
time was young he was old so it wasn't
an age deal it was very much the
blinders that they had put on so I just
have to disagree with her we got one up
here - thank you so much for coming and
speaking to us tonight um so I know you
mentioned Twitter and the conservative
blogosphere but besides talk radio where
do you see conservatives really making
an impact in media the the Washington
free beacon the Washington Examiner our
go-to online sites now Town Hall com to
which I'm a contributing editor is a
great aggregator but original or
journalism is primarily coming out of
those two and some of the old dogs like
National Review if you go to National
Review alianna Johnson I was talking
with John about today is one ferociously
talented reporters twenty-nine she's the
where's John what's your title
what's Eliana's title Washington editor
of National Review she's 29 years old
and that's because and she was a Fox
News producer under Sean Hannity then
she went to national view and began to
write a lot of the mostly young talent
is just forcing their way onto the stage
by virtue of productivity and story
selection and they dig dig dig
Eliana went to Nicaragua with Rand Paul
for a week nobody my age will do that
you know we just we're not going to go
do a medical mission Nicaragua to get a
human interest profile of Rand Paul you
have to be young and crazy to do
something like that and so there are
lots of young and crazy journalists out
there then to put it forward there are
so many places beyond those three but
I'm just saying if you wanted the most
credentialed thing I I or review there's
a Facebook phenomenon it's got the
highest traffic of any conservative site
out there not many people how many of
you read IR Review it's not it's not
very well-known but it's driving the
metric at the under 30
so we all get our media from different
places but I do not discount Twitter I
happen to believe that Twitter is the is
the shorthand for everything and in fact
I was reading along in Dan Balls's
wonderful book about the election 2012
called collision 2012 and I was stunned
of course I did the Washington DC a
thing Richard bigger you'll know this a
book is always checked first for its
index to make sure whether or not
they've referenced you and collision
2012 hadn't referenced me but I'm not
upset by that thing I know Dan Balz so I
started reading through I didn't expect
to find myself in the book and I did he
quoted a tweet that I issued in the
middle of the second debate first debate
between Romney and Obama and it
summarized a lot of what was going on
the Twittersphere you know there's no
need for a spin room anymore the spin on
a debate is over before the debate is
over the die is cast by Twitter before
it's done you know runs Twitter mostly
the sub-30 demographic their snarky
enough and their funny it's a delicate
enough touch it's so fast that if if we
unleash the train and the talent and the
truly good upon the Twitterverse will
win so I think it's those big platforms
to do longer form stories with the means
of production evident and Twitter and IR
and a couple of other sites right here
there's a microphone thank you very much
I guess I have basically two questions
or questioning partial statement going
back in history it seems to me William F
Buckley deserves some recognition here
relative to our conservative future
because without him there would be no
conservative future the other part and I
guess that shows my age no no that shows
your wisdom but the other side of that
is the left seems to think the social
media belongs to them I am convinced
that this is the genie in the bottle
that will unleash the conservative
revolution that is yet to come you are
you're absolutely right about the letter
I want to pause though and give you a
Buckley's story everyone had a Buckley
story I have one when I was young and
really full of myself age seventeen I
wrote a piece that I thought was really
the cat's pajamas
and I said that's a dating myself right
so I sent it to William F Buckley at the
national view with the suggestion that
he publish it immediately
what did Buckley send back a beautifully
gracious letter gosh I should grant even
as I think who knows when I wrote it was
had to be awful it was not in any way
because I was 17 what could I possibly
have known and and he wrote down unable
to use thank you so much for your
contribution I have a young friend who
will be matriculating at Harvard this
semester please look up Charles Kesler
from West Virginia so the first person I
met at Harvard in 1974 was Charles
Kesler brought together by William F
Buckley answering the mail of young
people who would write to him because of
that
that's who Buckley was answering the
mail of seventeen year olds in Warren
Ohio really the father of conservatism
had nothing better to do at this time
but he was incredibly gracious and
giving now as to the explosion of truth
that's what powered every revolution
that we've seen this for now revolutions
are a dangerous thing and I actually
would yield to dr. and dr. Arnn about
this because it's scary how fast
information moves and you end up in a
revolutionary moment with the capacity
to change things quickly as happened in
Egypt and they picked the wrong side
originally and CC's come back to
rebalance it but in Ukraine twice now
they have stopped the Soviets from
taking back the Russians from taking
back their empire less successfully the
second time than they did the first time
China knows it has a tiger an absolute
tiger on its hands on the other side of
my life in the world of Christian
witness I know that it's become
exponentially more effective to use new
media than any missionary could ever
have happened you know you've all of a
sudden you can reach across the world
and the Pope tweets for a reason and it
Francis and Benedict before him tweets
for a reason it's because it's out there
so if what we believe is true and truth
is affected self effectuating then we
should be winning and there are some old
barriers to blow over
I think we will win I don't think people
will put up with other that but there
are also some very deeply vested
interests that don't want to so I hope I
gave one other thing about Buckley
invented good television before there
was good television the firing line is
not known to anyone in this room that's
under 45 right I mean I may be under 50
the firing line was beautiful to watch
if you were young it was just a
beautiful thing to see because he would
get Malcolm Muggeridge on often and I
would sit there the words I didn't
understand the arguments I could barely
glimpse but Buckley's idiosyncratic
delivery the charisma of intelligence he
really they really set the standard very
high yes sir
earlier in your lecture you linked
George Will to rectitude within the last
year he was on this campus and in the
qat after his speech he advanced the
idea that the country will never get
better until the boomers are all dead
would you subscribe to that George Will
wrote a great column in direct wrote a
great column about Bill Clinton at the
end of the Clinton presidency which I
can quote from memory because it
impacted me so he may not be the worst
president we have ever had but he was
certainly the worst person to be
president in that he simply reflected
the the problems of his generation a
problem of entitlement and of over
abundance and a lack of suffering and a
lack of scarcity and a desire on the
part of that generations parents not to
put their kids through what he went
through so I think if he's referring
generally to the idea of self-indulgence
I mean we have borrowed 18 trillion
dollars in spent it and it was
illustrated to me this past weekend by
an individual said I went to lunch and
honey I told eight people at a
conference eight young people I'm going
to lunch would you like to go with my
friends and they all said yes that's
what you can't but you're going to pay
for our lunch
and that's what this generation has done
18 trillion dollars worth of debt and
it's a sad unfortunate truth so all dead
I don't know if necessarily dead but out
of the political circus that would be a
good thing and I'm a young boomer not an
old boomer I'm a young boomer born in 56
I still count and I think it goes up
through 61 the only problem
here's the good news and I was talking
about this earlier with with Larry
aren't about in reference to Tom cotton
Mike Pompeo there's a generation of
warriors rising up people who've been in
this war men and women all under the age
of 40 they are going to reconfigure
American politics if we just hang on
long enough a lot of people have gone to
the war they're very serious very
effective very discipline they're going
to remake American politics but we just
have to hang on for 10 more years yes
thank you so much I am a big fan of the
Hillsdale dialogues they're helping me
write my thesis so thank you oh good
that's more Larry and Paul than me but
good no no you're great um I had a
question because this evening I saw on
the Drudge Report that Obama still has a
50% approval rating and I'm mystified by
this how he can maintain that number you
had said earlier that Americans no
longer want to be lied to they're no
longer want to be deluded
can you explain perhaps why he still has
these numbers at a crucial moment in
time he didn't when it came time to
actually vote I think psychologically
it's a lot easier to say I like the
president I want him to succeed than it
is to say I don't like the president I
don't want him to succeed and and that's
just the American people are generous
and large hearted and they don't want
the President to fail in such an epic
failure its variant it's almost
unpleasant to consider how bad a
president he's been from the perspective
of anyone with children or grandchildren
you just know how badly awry the country
has gone Larry referred to it glancing
lean as a couple of minutes of remarks
there it's a very bad situation but they
don't want him to fail and they don't
want him to be as awful as he's been so
they'll say things like that but when it
came time to vote it was a repudiation
unlike any that we've had
you know very long time it was personal
but he is doctor instead of the radio
today chosen to interpret it his victory
is irreversible and as a result he
didn't care as State of the Union was
completely contemptuous to the vote of
people and to a certain extent the
immigration executive order rallied the
left to him so he's rallying the base
and that will be as that will fade this
president is going to be so wildly
unpopular by the end of these two years
because it's all you know gasoline has
fallen and we're all grateful for that
that's a lot of it we're not you know
Saudi Arabia is pumping as fast as they
can in order to bring down the regime in
Tehran and we're all a little bit
happier for that so that's part of his
thing but it's not a genuine economic
recovery and we all know that and so I'm
not I don't think that's stupid on our
part I think it's overly emotional on
our part here we have one right here
okay get the microphone they want to
record it you mentioned a lot of people
tonight that I certainly have a lot of
respect for like like Rush Limbaugh and
Charles Krauthammer I'm curious you
never mentioned Bill O'Reilly I was
curious as to what you think about him
no bill is a wonderful entertainer he is
a very provocative interviewer he
invented his own format which is is as I
say it's entertaining and he's done a
fine pretty good job of turning out some
books of general interest but it's not
my cup of tea because bill interrupts
like Chris Matthews and so his
counterpart is is Chris and I don't like
it and I can't do that he's been a guest
on my show many times and if you're
prepared to ask bill questions and
listen it's a great interview he's a
terrific interview in fact he'll always
say something newsworthy and noteworthy
but I don't hold them up as virtuous
journalism and because I I don't really
know what Bill believes as to politics
do you when he sat down with the
president for the Super Bowl interview
in fact glozell glozell
had a tougher question of the president
than bill did when she asked him about
the Cuba
how could you deal with those dictators
that was the toughest question you like
glozell got such bad press from the
American establishment media because she
was tougher on the president than any of
them in the White House press corps had
been by asking about the Cuba thing so
Bill's a wonderful entertainer it's a
tremendous success he's one of a kind
but he's not what I'm talking about and
he didn't didn't work and talk radio
either by the way didn't work oh I was
just wondering about you talked about
how conservatives are dominating talk
radio I just wondered could you give us
some more about how why they're
dominating talk radio specifically
rather than any other form yes I'm glad
you asked that because it reminds me of
something I didn't say the left tried
talk radio let's try talk radio many
times they had air America they've had a
number of individual shows my friend
bill press that a weekend show same time
I did how many of you listen to Bill
press every day so why does it fail they
have a built-in disadvantage called NPR
NPR is a subsidized left-wing outfit
that has for years taken the cream of
their pee ones we call them in our
business meeting the listener who
listens the most and taught them to
listen to NPR you can't get a liberal
away from NPR it's like cocaine
withdrawal for an addict to get a
liberal away from NPR so they can't
there's no market share for them to win
so that's one reason that we've won is
it they they don't they can't compete on
the field and they won't acknowledge
that NPR is liberal so they can't they
shackle themselves so they put their
best talent to work in mainstream media
and NPR and they never quite come out
with that the second thing that I'll
circle back to I said it once but
perhaps too quickly is its long-form
it's three hours I love working in
television I love radio and television
but if you if you forced me to it I'd
stick with radio for one thing my career
is longer because no one sees how old
you are
radio and you don't have to be 25 to be
in the radio but secondly you have
enough time to do an interview of any
length on any subject if it's good it
will attract an audience there is no
more long form journalism 60 minutes
passes for long form journalism and
they'll interview you for an hour and
they'll cut it down to eight minutes and
that will be the end of it and it's
ghastly most television is ghastly and
so yesterday Meet the Press I did the I
did the math today hour-long show take
out the advertising for guests on the
panel with Chuck Todd I was on for five
minutes
that's an eternity in television that
was I got to make three or four points I
went in there one you make a point about
Iran is Yemen was I knew we were talking
about Yemen and I want to make the point
that Yemen is not about Yemen it's about
Iran right so it's about the Islamic
empire extending itself through Beirut
through Damascus even through South
America I want to make a point that the
Iowa freedom forum was mostly about
common core people think it was about
immigration know that I checked this out
with James Holman of Politico fine young
reporter 28 years old
superstar rising just works works works
works works and I sent James a tweet
public tweak James how many times does
Common Core come up in the course of
today he tweeted me back he'd been in
the room for every minute of the session
tweeting away at least two dozen times
so I brought this up to chuck on the
panel and got the message out to the
three million people that watch Meet the
Press that common core is the issue that
is driving domestic politics in the
Republican primary yeah this is news the
liberal elites right they can't possibly
believe that's true how could anyone be
against improving education and parents
are waving their hands and saying stop
this is a nightmare this is a beast and
I can't do the homework and my kids are
upset and then the third thing I want to
make it was a point some of you will
like and some of you won't is that I
think Mitt Romney well I'd done some
reporting 80% certain he's going to run
for president I want to make the point
that it's unique circumstance in
American politics if you lose the
election you don't get invited back four
years later nobody was clamoring for
John McCain to run in 2012 after he lost
in 2008
no one was clamoring for excuse me who
lost in our 2004 cycle John Kerry to
come back in 2008 no one want no
Democrat wanted to come back Chuck
pointed out that Al Gore had a little
boomlet a little boomlet in in 2004
after he had lost in 2000 no one wanted
Bob Dole back in the list in 2000 after
he lost in 1996 no one wanted George
Herbert Walker Bush back in 1996 after
he lost in 1992 why is there this Romney
thing because he has a hard core base of
support between 30 and 40% of the party
Mike Huckabee got 40,000 votes in Iowa
in 2008 Rick Santorum and Mitt Romney
each got about 30,000 votes
in 2012 in Iowa he's got money he's
going to be in Jeb is going to be in
we're going to have 15 people in the
Republican primary we're going to have a
brokered convention that this is I just
think the rules are going to work out
and that's a good thing
it's going to be a terrific thing I want
everybody in there making arguments
doctor and I we're talking about this on
the air today that draws attention to
our side and illuminates the political
landscape with continuing conversation
last night in Palm Springs Rand Paul Ted
Cruz and Marco Rubio sat down before the
coke summit the Koch brothers promised
to raise 900 million dollars to spend on
this election cycle uhaah I like that
spend it on radio but I'd want that's
lightning in a bottle
Ted Cruz has been on this campus I don't
know if Marco Rubio and Rand Paul been
here but I know Ted Cruz has been I take
that show on the road that's better than
Barnum and Bailey I know because I do
this all around the country I just have
to bring one or two interesting people
together and folks show up because
they're interested look at you why are
you here it's January it's Michigan
because you're hungry for some substance
that you don't get in the ordinary media
if you were getting this at home you
know this is an aside we're running late
there used to be something called
Chautauqua how many of you know what you
talk Way is I did they are they're still
out there and they still operate they
operate on
premise when the Americans in the
summertime would want to hear lectures
about important topics delivered by
people with expertise in their field
that's what this is it's just Chautauqua
four times a year with Matt and the
Hillsdale staff making it possible for
people to come here and and have an
extraordinary intellectual experience
that's what's missing in our media and
that's I think that 2016 election is
going to bring us one more Matt's
cutting me off you know it's a hook they
all want to go home go ahead I think one
other aspect mr. Hewett or I should call
you Hughes since we had large numbers is
that with with conservative talk radio
unlike other things there's not the
Gruber effect what I mean is that we as
you treat us as listeners with great
reverence with great affection and you
treat us as but we are intelligent human
beings that can handle the truth and can
can analyze issues from different
perspectives or different aspects maybe
we didn't think about before so that
that respect for your audience and
treating them that they are intelligent
human beings is so attractive and that's
why we listen hour after hour thank you
you know I wish I'd said that it's going
into my remarks it is absolutely true
that I am Not Afraid to play the other
side's speeches at length I play the
president's press conference I'm not
afraid that my audience is going to be
misled and I don't talk over people and
I'll interview any liberal there's a
reason why Democrats won't come on my
show if they're elected they won't get
out of there and it's not because I mean
or abusive it's that you just can't
answer these collection more couldn't
last 30 minutes with me because if you
start asking about the sanctions bill in
Iran and about their habit of acting
since the 1978 revolution there is no
way to defend a nuclear deal with Iran
it is impossible and he knows that so he
will not go in arms way which is why by
the way as to systemic bias back to the
last I'll finish by going to the first
question
why is it that if any Republican goes on
any Sunday show our mainstream media
they will be grilled absolutely grilled
on the specifics of their policy it will
be relentless it will not stop Tim
Russert asked the late Tim Russell he
was very good at his job
asked Dick Cheney eight questions in a
row about his heart condition eight
about his heart condition he wouldn't
let it go if the president goes in
harm's way
he gets one quits like a tame set of
reporters they do not pursue and he
never puts himself in harm's way and
it's a shame that we've come to accept
that and the reason we do is because of
the systemic bias and manners it's okay
to attack conservatism it is simply not
done to attack liberalism not our class
darling kind of snobbery but I think
that's being overturned by Twitter and
as someone here said we're winning
because you the truth is just relentless
it's 24/7 and if we're just gracious and
we don't have to worry about anyone
persuading our audience of anything our
audience is smart you know then and by
the way we have the statistics to prove
it higher education higher income more
mobility the reason we sell what we sell
is because they're there I sell cruises
that cost ten thousand dollars of birth
who's going to buy that right that's a
very select audience and the the fact
the matter is we're very comfortable
with our people we understand that they
are not going to be shined on and if I
ever try it
boy the flag goes out the penalty flag
goes out in a hurry they know it thank
you so much for having me thanks for
supporting Hillsdale good night